[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH YGUADO: My
name is Josh Yguado.
I'm co-founder and
president of SGN.
SGN is the fastest growing
mobile game developer
at scale in the West.
Four of us founded the
company, and since then, we've
grown to over 200 employees.
Our goal is to
continue that growth.
Right now we've got four
games that are top-grossing.
And we want to continue
to expand the portfolio
of top-grossing games.
All of our products launch
across multiple platforms
simultaneously.
Getting that right
can be very hard.
If you want to succeed
in this industry,
you have to make sure
that you're constantly
iterating on your product.
When you're at scale, that
can be very difficult,
because there are tens of
millions of players every day
enjoying your game.
MATTHEW CASERTANO:
I'm Matthew Casertano.
I'm SVP of game
operations at SGN.
Testing has really helped us
move from subjective criteria
to objective criteria.
The inability to test led to
a lot of qualitative decision
making.
Now with the tools
that we have, we're
able to make
quantitative-based decisions
and use a very
short feedback loop.
For Cookie Jam, we ran a
really interesting icon test
in which we toyed with the
background of the icon.
This led to an 8% increase
in our conversion rate.
We use the agency that
specializes in the preferences
of Japanese consumers.
And we came up with
an icon that we
use heavy pinks and yellows
that performed 12% better
with the Japanese consumers.
Another game that we ran
experiments on was Panda Pop.
Previously, we had
an icon with a baby
panda flying through the
air surrounded by bubbles.
Our designers came up
with a cool concept
with the baby panda.
Instead of flying, he was
frolicking among the bubbles.
When we switched
over the icon, we
saw an uptick of 25% in organic
traffic and an uptick of 4%
on the install rate.
We ran a really interesting
icon test in Book of Life.
The icon that featured
Maria performed 10% better
than the icon that
we had previously,
which featured Chuy.
Additionally, for Book of
Life, we tested different copy
for our description.
We found that the enhanced copy,
which was a little bit more
direct and shorter, performed
4% better than the existing copy
that we had in the store.
Store experiments have helped
SGN improve its ROI equation
by improving our costs through
higher conversion rates,
and improving our LTVs through
higher retention rates.
Each test that we've run,
we've learned something new.
It's provided us with
actionable results that have
helped improve our business.
JOSH YGUADO: My
first piece of advice
is no matter how big you
are, you have to stay nimble.
Be willing to innovate.
Be willing to fail.
You also have to
love what you do.
So we love to play casual games.
I think that's core to
making a successful company,
and to making a game
that people want to play.
[MUSIC PLAYING]